morning my converse high top all-stars
in honor of today's guest
dr lawrence krauss author of so many
books uh to read their titles would take
us to the end of the podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
most of the supporters of the multiverse
are fellow traveling along with string
theory and you are a very very prominent
you know kind of outspoken critic of of
string theory and what it might mean
then you see you see i get i get labeled
well i get laid many things i'm a critic
of hype is what i'm a criminal when it
comes to sign so i was a critic of the
hype associated with string theory
i wrote a whole book called hiding in
the mirror which is really about the
search for extra dimensions and it
explains why string theory is very well
motivated
so this
as a as a fundamental area of physics
it's very well motivated i happen to
think
probably more than loop quantum gravity
but but but um
but it's the hype it's this
interesting idea that was claimed to be
able to
tell us everything and it's told us
virtually nothing except providing an
incredible amount useful mathematical
tools
to apply to other physical systems
anyway yeah actually i i want to turn to
that because your friend stephen hawking
late great stephen hawking he would
often you know concede bets
and on the basis of uh of of a proof
from say juan maldasena in you know
five-dimensional ads cft uh you can
recover beckon scene hawking you can get
all sorts of information but i want to
ask you like i mean i i feel like he
conceded that too easily like how do we
know that i think the ncft even exists
it's true no i i think no i think look
uh
steve is a wonderful man but he's also a
very astute
um
promoter and and i think he did some
things he did because he he realized
they would get attention
and i i i tend to think that was the
case yeah by the way i'm really pissed
that i had i had what i thought should
have been a famous bet with with hawking
and we'll check which i won it was
shortly after um the dark energy was
discovered
that i argued and there was a great deal
of of all this hype about all good
testaments about we'll be able to
measure
you know that it's changing in blah blah
and i and i said within a decade there
will be no
nothing that will be able to tell us
that that it it it
that dark energy is changing there'll be
nothing that will able to tell you that
it is a cosmological constant and
therefore there's nothing that tells you
it isn't and and there'll be no there'll
be no observational data and they say oh
no no no within a decade
because in his book which i have
somewhere here and i talk a beautiful
question
written in 2014
uh he makes a claim that within five
years super symmetry will be discovered
so yeah i feel of frank that as sir
roger penrose once said though the
quickest way to get rich is to make a
bet with stephen hawking because no
matter what you bet he's going to
concede because of the attention i think
and uh and and oftentimes he would have
two different positions
but you don't become rich by being with
stephen hawk you just get some notoriety
so first of all whether i
you know
putting people in camps worries me
yeah i'm not i'm not a fan of this
claimed progress in strength here i have
great respect
for
for the work that's being done in many
ways which i mean i edwin is another
friend of mine and someone i admire
tremendously for their abilities um but
but you know but string theory isn't
quantum corner man it hasn't explained
the world
but
but that has nothing to do with them
whether a multiverse is a very sensible
idea the the the really sensible
multiverse the well-motivated multiverse
is not the multiverse of string theory
the extra dimensional many universes the
the only one that is inescapable it
seems to me is the one from inflation
one of the knocks against string theory
is that it uh it doesn't have um you
know it doesn't make predictions that
are testable and therefore uh cannot be
cannot be falsified and then he went
into the black hole entropy that it can
be reproduced to show the degrees of
freedom that back in
a two-dimensional black hole yeah in a
two-dimensional black hole which we
don't live in by the way exactly right
so i mentioned that and then he said
okay so i said come on cameron and he
said um so for example if you take an
electron it has a mass and if you
compute the mass of the electron in the
fundamental units of physics which is
planck mass it's a very tiny mass in
plank mass so lawrence what what do you
what do you make of that what would you
give cameron if you takes your takes a
cloud he's basically saying the electron
mass is prediction it could have been 10
to the minus 32
of the of the planck mass but it's not
it's between 10 minus 31 and 10 to the
minus one um a big range but it's a
prediction it could be wrong it could be
falsified i don't think it's well look
i don't think it's worth getting hung up
because the theory is just so premature
such an early it's not it's not a
well-defined theory yet i think and i
mean it's got a lot of great ideas and
maybe it'll relate to the real universe
at some point
um
it's as as i'd like to say and this is a
joke of frank's you know it's promising
but it's been promising and promising
for a long time but um what really
disappointed me the most to tell you the
truth is the one thing
if string theory had predicted a
cosmological constant
it would have been
great but in fact not only did it not
predict a cosmological constant but
generally it has a hard time even
existing with one
and and um without a negative one anyway
and um yeah and so
so and that's the one
i'm personally convinced that we won't
understand the energy of empty space
until we have a quantum theory of
gravity i suspect they're intimately
involved with each other
uh
and and so the one thing that i would
want a purported theory of quantum
gravity to tell me something about would
be the cosmological constant generally
string theory would tell would suggest
that what we're seeing now is a
temporary aberration of will ultimately
be a negative uh cosmological constant
but again then i have uh people like uh
michio kaku coming on and saying no
because i asked him i was like where in
string theory does one find the muon g
minus two anomaly where do i find the
large hadron collider beauty results
these anomalies and so forth where do i
find hubble tension
and he says it's all there and i said
what do you mean he says you just have
to tell me the vacuum state and i say
well why is it my job as an
experimentalist tell you what the vacuum
state is of your theory and yet on the
same token the swampland et cetera it
seems hopeless lawrence and and i'm
wondering why is it that that you get so
much attention from people like you know
kaka with the god equation and stephen
hawking even talking about m theory as
if it's proven as if all
because it sounds profound and everyone
wants the next best thing then you know
it after einstein and if string theory
were a theory
of of of uh
of space and time then
obviously
in some level
and if there and a complete theory that
from which all the forces of nature were
derivable then obviously
it's in there because ever you know if
it really were a theory of all the
forces of nature then all the things we
measure must be a part of that
so so it's a tautology almost so of
course in principle it's there but
we don't but first of all a we don't
know how to do it but more importantly
than that we don't know if it is we
don't know if it if this incredibly
fascinating area of mathematical physics
is a fundamental description of our
universe and i don't really care about
at this point
whether it makes predictions that you
could test because i i think that's
we're way away from that the question we
really have to address is that there's
no evidence yet string theory
describes
uh uh
our universe if you enjoyed this video i
know you'll want to check out my
interview with frank wilczak winner of
the 2004 nobel prize
in this conversation frank and i discuss
this fascinating new book called
fundamentals which outlines 10 key
principles to understand our universe
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]